bon daniel lampart en circulation un oui
en fait comme d'habitude roule
tranquillement l'arrivée 2 tu m'entends
moteur en route on cherche un petit peu
alors que possible
[Musique]
il
on a ce que tout soit prêt
eddy curry au 1er feu en tourne à droite
a vraiment m
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la moto c'était un peu au départ une
idée un peu banale une question de
commodité pour déplacer dans paris en
ville puis c'est venu ici en vacances
pendant l'été j'avais une petite moto
une 125 et puis je voyais des gars passé
avec des grosses motos ça me faisait un
peu envie mais enfin disons que l'idée
initiale donc c'était de pouvoir se
garer dans paris pas trop sous filet
puisque c'est interdit qu'on n'en pas
sans permis mais enfin dix ans pour voir
se déplacer plus rapidement et le plus
indépendant et puis après les premières
leçons et vous allez peut-être le
comprendre d'après quand vous verrez ça
sur l'autoroute
après les premières leçons c'est la
notion de vitesse et d'indépendance et
contrairement à tout ce qu'on peut
c'est la notion de sécurité c'est à dire
qu'on a l'impression qu'on peut échapper
à tout aussi un obstacle se présente se
présente il suffit d'ouvrir et quand on
ouvre on a pu l'ouvrir accéléré très
fort au nom on échappe on s'échappe si
deux voitures sur serre on accélère les
voitures sont loin derrière c'est fillon
on est sur la machine ça c'est la
maniabilité ça c'est ce qu'on passe pour
le permis on est sur la machine on l'a
je m'excuse de parler comme ça mais
c'est vraiment ça on l'a entre les
jambes et sous le ventre et il se passe
physiquement quelque chose
d'impressionnant de vraiment
extraordinaire
c'est la vie devant soi
l'odeur
voilà alors bon
j'ai un petit peu tardif quand même pas
mal j'ai un petit but est accélérée à
bon port oui à une venue ton seul homme
ça va le truck puisque sans attente
d'habitude d'ilop les points blancs de
foin blanc à cause de ces jeunes vont la
planche bien stable il rachetait c'est
bon et la bombe à 5 cm n'entrant pas
dans la langue ça va bien ça va bien
aller jusqu'à dire voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
là
m
oh
[Musique]
c'est la sela 6 29e ça c'est un truc je
sais mon époque ça existe que je joue
sans même savoir s'il existe sauf le
début ça va ça c'est un ton mineur
maintenant que ces familles
les émeutes
ça c'est quoi la bémol mais bémol ça
c'est un coup alors que ça s'est réglé
mois ces thèmes majeurs est le suivant
si bémol
voila l'exemple type d'accord que je me
sers gaulle abbas qui changent et c'est
suffisant pour changer le nom de tous et
c'est l'exemple type des choses que je
sais pas ça je suis pas en train de
prendre une leçon de piano
je suis en train en fait de travailler
c'est à dire à ma façon j'ai plutôt un
autre façon et je vous explique pourquoi
parce que je n'écris pas la musique
c'est pas fondamental pour moi pour
faire ce que je fais je ne suis pas
beethoven donc c'est pas compliqué à ce
point d'appui en plus ce n'est pas une
façon de travailler qui me conviendrait
j'ai trois éléments pour travailler
d'abord moi je me mets en vain puisque
ces deux mois que ça sort même si ça
sort aussi de ce que j'entends à côté
des fois et puis il ya en deux le
magnétophone qui est un peu ma ma
feuille de papier mais ce ne l'est pas
dans le sens de l'écriture dans le sens
de la mémoire
c'est ça
et puis alors après il ya en
l'occurrence hervé qui est musicien qui
joue avec moi depuis dix bons jours au
public la bande au gentil public
hervé qui jouent avec moi depuis
maintenant 6 7 ans et que je rencontre
chaque fois que je prépare un disque
pour faire ce qu'on appelle des grillons
et c'est ça des grilles je sais pas si
vous le voyez des grace et ça c'est les
harmonies de mes chansons comme ayant un
c'est un bouillon alors on fait sans âme
parce que je ne connais pas le nom des
harmoniques je fais facile j'en connais
quelques joueurs dont je vais vous
m'avez entendu dire tout à leur donnant
certains s'accordent c'est pas pour
frimer c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
vrai glace et je sais que ça c'est un
fait mineur et ça c'est un vrai noël etc
mais il ya des accords qui se complique
comme celui qu'on a fait après à vrai
dire pour moi c'est pas important que ça
s'appelle comme ça
ce qui est important c'est le son que ça
mais par contre c'est important pour les
musiciens qui vont jouer avec moi alors
hervé à votre inscrit tout ça clairement
et lorsqu'on répète qu on est en studio
qu'on enregistre voile alors il donne sa
aux musiciens et à partir de ça on
cherche des arrangements ce qui fait
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'un rongeur ont
fait un travail de groupe
voilà et hervé lui emmène les cassettes
chez lui les cassettes que je fais et
puis travaille dessus
c'est un peu pour expliquer tout ça et
pour dire simplement que c'est un état
d'esprit ne pas vouloir prendre
d'arrangeur qui font d'une mélodie
bonnes ou mauvaises
quelque chose soit de trop grandiloquent
souhaite trop simple des choses comme ça
alors on le fait un travail d'équipé
avec des musiciens qui sont chacun à
leur instrument
ce qui n'est pas le cas des arrangeurs
un arrangeur joue du piano il arrange la
batterie arrange la basse et la range la
guitare tout cela des fois il arrange ça
c'est vraiment le cas de le dire on se
fait bien arrangés qui transcrit un
principe est ce que c'est pas
obligatoirement que ça convient à la
chanson que ça convient au bout qu'on a
alors au moins on sait que chaque
musicien à son instrument et en principe
ce sens et pouvoir donner le meilleur de
cet instrument et c'est pour ça que je
fais confiance aux gens qui m'entourent
et puis ça donne
ça me rappelle ma jeunesse en plus j'ai
pas vivre enfin je suis plus jeune non
plus et j'ai commencé par faire des
groupes de rock et j'ai la sensation
toujours de faire de la rock musique
maintenant pas du rock'n'roll c'est sûr
je vais pas du bilal et ou de souche
comme ça où tu m'as dit cochrane
j'ai la sensation de faire de la rock
musique et
française en plus parce que je crois que
ça existe aussi et alors en travaillant
comme on sait la avec hervé s'éteint
c'est du travail de musicien lettre du
musicien peu profane dans ce qui est bon
ce qui me concerne mais c'est bien parce
que je crois que si je connaissais tout
tout seul je m'ennuierais et ça me
sommes par exemple ça me plairait
d'avoir des liens d'amitié avec des gens
comme hervé avec des gens qui
travaillent avec moi et ça me cacherais
toute ma vie ça m'intéresserait plus du
tout quoi voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
quand je pense qu'on est en train de
faire de l'exclusivité là c'est
formidable
mais ces dames des landes
[Musique]
j'avais rêvé si fort d'un autre décor g
de lune de miel ou seule vanne en
liberté au milieu des morts en comptant
les mains
[Musique]
jeudi
oh oh oh
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
c'est le montage de la structure
ce qu'on amène et ça fait beaucoup de
choses c'est bien on arrive dave pour
tous avec un gros semi remorque
pour essayer d'amener beaucoup de
lumière et consorts c'est une question
de conception il ya des gens qui font le
spectacle avec peu de temps un peu de
lumière sont que l époque où en vie
c'est mieux de
d'avoir de sable ça fait partie
je trouve ça fait partie de la magie du
spectacle je sais comme moi quand je
vais un spectacle je supporte pas que ce
soit mal éclairé alors même au début je
vous rappelle il ya un an et demi deux
ans quand on n'avait pas encore beaucoup
de moyens on
on chantait à perte c'est vraiment joué
un peu à faire mais pour avoir une
structure saine conséquente
et à voir quelque chose vraiment bien
d'amener que je ne sais même pas ce que
c'est ce qui me manque le plus
marquantes comme je vais voir un
spectacle qui me paraît un petit peu
déçu il a dit ça veut pas dire tout le
monde doit faire comme ça enfin voilà
alors là vous avez vu les techniciens
travaillent et travail de réglage de
présentation d'angle des linéaires fait
des essais de fumer parce que la fumée
ça me permet de mieux cerner le halo des
projecteurs pour les bacs depuis le soir
ainsi pour les gens ce fut spectaculaire
et puis là donc on va attaquer la
répétition d'un nouveau morceau vie en
fait à l'ancien manceau mais qu'on n'a
pas fait depuis longtemps
et puis on va régler tous les sons des
instruments
cela dit au coût de faire pour toi
recoller hervé est ce que tu peux faire
une ligue
des du morceau
pour philippe
[Musique]
à
papa dada papin d'un pain d'abadan je
suis bien
chez
je suis bien je suis bien
[Musique]
je suis